[Music]
i'm really excited to
announce our last but absolutely not the
least keynote speakers
uh roger ping and hilary parker the host
of
not so standard deviations
if you've never heard of it before
really fantastic podcast
they've never invited me to be a guest
speaker but fortunately
i'm not bitter about that at all
but seriously a very long-term fans of
roger and hillary
uh roger has been a very a supporter of
the tidy verse really before
it was the tidy verse and i think his
user 2018 keynote does a better job of
kind of articulating the philosophy
and the benefits of the tidy verse than
i have ever managed
i'm also very fortunate to call uh
hillary uh
a friend uh hillary is a fantastic data
scientist i've had a number of really
insightful conversations with her
one recent one which led me to really
understand like one of the things
that i do is design but as well as being
a data scientist
at stitch fix hillary i'm also very
lucky that hillary is has acted as my
stylist and she actually has picked out
the clothes i'm wearing
today
so i'd like you to please join me in
welcoming hillary and roger
okay so you're gonna get a little behind
the scenes action here
because uh the listeners of our show
don't see this
but we have to do this every time you
know when you're dealing with a
high-stakes situation like this
safety comes first yeah right so um
we have a checklist that we go through
every time so uh
we're gonna go through the checklist uh
okay hillary hardwired yeah i guess we
don't really need that
vpn turned off yeah my work vpn
causes problems with our number of
connections yes
wi-fi turned off oh actually i haven't
turned off my wi-fi
okay uh
reboot your router yeah yeah almost
always my internet is yeah yeah
yeah um verify microphone i think the
people in the back they seem to know
what they're doing
um verify recording we are recording um
all right hardwired i'm not recording
today
uh how's being written not doing that
we did once do a whole podcast episode
where we did not record that's right
yeah so once that happened like that's
how that made it onto the checklist
yeah we did a blameless postmortem
uh levels seem to be okay yeah all right
and
it is close to five o'clock yeah so um
verify that my cat's been you fed your
cat yeah
yeah she does like from four to five she
starts to interrupt things
that was more of an issue when you were
in melbourne yes yeah yeah
um so all right so i think we're go for
launch
yeah all right so uh welcome to not so
standard deviations
episode 100.
uh i'm roger pang from the johns hopkins
bloomberg school of public health and
i'm here with hilary parker of stitch
fix
um this so this episode is our first
ever live episode
yeah um it's i guess ironically not
gonna be about our or our studio
yeah but um it's possible we showed up
at the wrong conference
um but uh but i think i hope you'll
enjoy it i think it'll be fun
yeah yeah um we also did some prep like
unusually uh usually we kind of show up
and
call each other and say i was thinking
about talking about this
and so this time we actually have some
materials yes
yeah all right so i thought there are
probably a few
people in the audience who haven't heard
of or heard our podcast so i thought
we thought we just talked a little bit
about kind of why we're here what we're
doing
why we're doing this um and uh so i
guess
this started in 2015 right after the our
open psy
unconference here in san francisco where
hillary and i kind of caught up
and i sent her an email i said hey uh
i think the subject of the email was i
want to broadcast your opinions to the
world
yeah because you know hillary has a few
opinions
and i thought this there's nothing the
internet likes more than a strongly
opinionated person all right
so um you know i sent her an email said
hey i think we could do a data science
podcast
the i don't think there's exactly what
i'm thinking about out there already in
terms
of other data science podcasts um and so
you know do you want to do it and uh so
she got back to me she said yes
and i sent her a wall of text emails
saying here's what i think we should do
and then there was no response
yeah but then a week later i apologized
a lot
yes and it was true that my boss quit
that week so there was like some reason
but
yeah it was mostly the wall of text but
yes and then we just went for it yeah
for five years and so or
almost five years yeah um so 99 episodes
yeah and so here we are so we've been
talking about a lot of things
um and one of the things that over the
past five years and one of the things
that we realize as we're preparing what
for this keynote is that we have like a
record of everything we've set
yeah yeah so i wanted to make sure
there's a visual impact here
but um i actually printed out the
transcripts
of every episode and leaf through them
um because it's kind of rare that you
have
the ability to see what you were
thinking over a period of time like this
aside from kind of like a personal
journal which i have
joked that the podcast is a little bit
of like a personal journal
but um but yeah so we wanted to look
back and see
what themes were coming up and you know
we kind of
we never set out with an agenda for this
although i kind of thought
you did at first but um we just wanted
to chat
and then what was surprising was that we
actually got some places during these
chats and so
part of the the reason i wanted to look
back through these transcripts was to
see how thoughts evolved over
time so just be before we move on to the
next thing
i sort of mentioned yeah as we were kind
of leading up to this keynote
you know they asked us to do this a
while back you know and we saw
kind of who else was going up you know
so i mean i think so for example jj's
keynote
yeah uh yesterday was you know was
amazing yeah um
and a lot and you know maybe
coincidentally or not
a lot of themes that we had been
discussing in terms of open source and
yeah
and um and for those of you who are
wondering we're not going to talk about
that
yeah we're not going to talk about open
source at all so
even though our episodes have been
leading up to that and again we
like may have had some information there
uh
that emboldened those conversations but
um look out for episode 101 yeah episode
101 we'll get back on track with that
but um yeah i've we wanted to touch
on those the keynotes have been awesome
so far
and especially i mean jj's was really
good
and we were joking about the fact that
uh didn't realize what a nerd he was
or what like a policy nerd
i told him it warmed my heart when he
brought up the case history of the
delaware supreme court
um you know nothing more riveting yeah
nothing more riveting than a little bit
of corporate case law you know
exactly but and it's just so lucky that
someone who like had so much interest in
public policy
but then became like a highly productive
coder for many years
and then like circled back and brought
them together like
it's unusual so um and then yeah the uh
the second keynote with all that data
visualization like really spoke to me
um because at citrix i work a lot with
outfit data
there's a lot of imagery and fashion
right and so
um i was really inspired by that about
like different ways to visualize the
data
and actually jj also was talking about
this like
um the book was called uh shop class is
soulcraft
and like this idea of like touching the
data and like making the data yourself
and
looking through this transcript actually
you would mention um scott zieger
talking about like writing the data down
by hand and so
i just i thought that was awesome and
that's actually comes from uh
john tukey who talks about scratching
the numbers down oh really oh
there you go so i have to say when i we
saw that the
two people the two people from google
were going to talk in the keynote we
didn't know what it was going to be but
i was like oh that one's going to be
good actually so
they're going to be like very polished
very prepared
let's do the opposite yeah right
run in the opposite direction of
whatever they do yeah that was where the
idea of the live episode came from
and then jenny's talk was great too yeah
um
she always has an amazing yeah
she she has an incredible ability to
just kind of see that higher level
of stuff after having been in the
trenches for so long exactly yeah like
going into the detail and understanding
the nitty-gritty but then being able to
zoom out
and like create the paradigm for it it's
like not easy
so yeah good work
don't get too comfortable though yeah no
but i feel like this conference has been
awesome
and we have like we have fodder for like
many episodes like going following up on
this stuff so
it's such a great vibe this is your
first
this is my first r studio accomplished
that's right yeah yeah so
um so we went through this so one of the
ideas that we had for this keynote was
to kind of go through our thought
process for the last five years
and which is made a lot easier by
looking at the transcripts listening to
the audio hearing what we've been
talking about
yeah and and one of the things as we did
that in preparation
um we noticed a number of kind of
interesting moments of course
and kind of a recurring theme yeah um
one of the one of the interesting
moments that we had actually early on in
the podcast was
our first and only really kind of use of
profanity
um and uh i i mean i just want to ask
maybe do a quick poll who thinks
it was me and who thinks it was hillary
who thinks it was hillary
wow who thinks it was me
about 50 50 all right let me play this
uh this clip
when people use spreadsheets they're
trying to avoid like syntax poultry and
yeah data structure bolstering because
we have a lot of that in any scripted
language where
you have to know a fair amount of syntax
and get fairly facile with data
structures
thank you jenny bryan
it was a really popular episode it was
it was like super early days and
jenny was defending spreadsheets
essentially or like
like talking about having empathy
explaining the attraction of
spreadsheets
yeah yeah another theme one of the
most controversial things i think we've
ever discussed on the podcast
um involves this topic here
and i want to point out that you got an
oatmeal raisin cookie what is the
problem
you're like the tenth person who's like
who's called me out of there
you're terrible like why does anyone
choose this
they're delicious okay
i'm just have to enjoy them in private
that's yeah as you should
[Music]
that that's like a dagger in the heart
yeah as you should
yeah oatmeal cookies to this day
get us a lot of feedback yeah and um
terrible um and
apparently there's a lot a whole a huge
plate of them outside
you know ready for ready for me to eat
since no one else wants i also love that
episode we literally
recorded in a jimmy john that's right
like that was
we like met i was in town for my
brother's wedding
and we like met in the middle between dc
my brother lives in dc and we met in the
middle between dc and baltimore
like out of jimmy john's and recorded it
and you ordered an oatmeal raisin
that's right yeah hence the interesting
soundtrack
yeah um the other kind of
one recurring theme that we have has
played out over multiple episodes is
hillary trying to get me to do stuff
yeah and so one of those things is uh
getting netflix apparently
so my only problem actually is that i
don't have uh
i don't have netflix oh come on you can
shell out
like it's like eight dollars in the
brother
episode three episode three yeah
episode 28. oh the other piece of news
that's really important is that i
finally got netflix
and 28 is like a year later right uh
yeah
yeah because we do once every two months
so yeah
two weeks yeah yeah yeah once every two
weeks uh
episode 36 so if you have access to hbo
highly recommend oh hbo okay now you're
like i have to buy another service
yeah i bought netflix for you
sorry yeah this one's an hbo exclusive
yeah all right it's 14.99 a month
so we went from eight to 14.99 yeah i
just kind of wonder what i'm gonna have
to
pay next and then episode 70 yeah
are there on netflix uh i would assume
so i don't know who knows what's on
netflix these days
so apparently i wasn't really watching
it yeah like okay so this is
i have some follow-up which is that
so i have some notes here episode six
you say
i love movies okay episode 13 you say
i'm a film nerd
and then like many times you talked
about this script book thing
which was like predicting whether a
movie would be successful based on its
script
right like out like algorithms for doing
that and then
while hickey came on and you like read
his blog post about like books versus
movies and you know about steven
spielberg table reads
yeah i wanna i feel like i want the
visual of like handing you like
like here's all the times you've talked
about movies
but like do you not watch movies like
how does this work
like are you just interested in movies
like intellectually
and never watch them i just i infer
their content
no but i like i really want the answer
here like do you watch netflix this
isn't an act
yeah no um you know things have slowed
down
in terms of my movie watching activity
but you enjoy like the craft i do yeah
so okay so then that's just weird i just
want you to know that
so noted yeah anyway the transcripts
like really brought that home for me
because i uh i had never like put those
together and i didn't realize you said
early on that you were a film nerd
you're like i love living in la
or you lived in l.a in grad school yeah
anyway so those were kind of like our
fun uh going back and
recording themes but what we really
wanted to talk about was this kind of
overarching thing that actually hadley
kind of uh
alluded to which is the idea of the
world design and data science
and um we one
this was something we chewed on for so
long of essentially like
how do you do data analysis um and
one thing that really struck me looking
at it was that
literally in episode one we talk about
it
a lot and actually for a long time i
thought that this was why you wanted to
do
the podcast it was like to solve this
problem i had no agenda
and it is yeah it is surprising to look
at that first transcript to see how many
plant seeds are planted
exactly like we actually talked about
we we hit words and themes that were
like
were kind of where we got to but i don't
think we had a way of recognizing
that those were going to be important at
the time so we have three clips
from episode one just to be clear we
started this episode talking about our
cat ladies
yeah that's right agenda was not super
strong yeah and our cat lady
this is like a little dated at this
point but it was like this hashtag for
like
seeing your cat on your keyboard while
you're
writing r this happens to me all the
time and
anyway yeah so anyway this is from the
first episode
we have this habit of like telling
people
like giving people a bunch of choices
right
like you could do this you could do that
you could do regression you could do
smoother you could you know whatever
just pick there's like five different
models that you could you know
or strategies that you could implement
uh but we often don't like tell people
how to choose between those yeah types
of things you know like that's almost
like it's almost like we
explicitly don't do it the recording
quality
in the early days was i know you can
really tell from these clips the
variants of my recording
quality like personally but um let me
just put these down
um but yeah like so you had to set that
clip up a little bit more
you'd like had an experience teaching a
stat class
where at the end someone essentially
said to you like
as a statistician you i think you did a
good job of telling me things to do and
you told me
things definitely things not to do uh
but now how do i know what to do right
yeah basically like thanks for teaching
me all this stuff i still don't know
anything
yeah i still know nothing and i still
know like you set me down with the
data set i don't know like how to
proceed right yeah yeah this person and
this person got an a in the classes
yeah by far and away and my favorite
part about that too is that you kind of
set it up as like
you like you were like good point and it
was the second to last lecture
they like go to your office and like sit
down and try to like
write it out like okay here's what to do
here's what data analysis is
in one lecture yeah like here's how to
craft the perfect analysis yeah it
didn't work
yeah it didn't work uh i can't i think i
came away with a few bullet points
yeah um yeah i had a lot more thinking
to do apparently that was about i guess
10 years ago now wow yeah yeah
so okay so the second one second clue i
was thinking when you're saying that is
that
like part of a successful data analysis
is convincing someone of something
and that's like that is inherently like
a one-on-one process
yeah yeah so we touched on like this
like what does success look like right
yeah like that was kind of what this
woman was getting at it's like okay
i have to do something i have to
accomplish something like what is that
thing
and how do i decide how to do it right
yeah
and we don't we don't touch the hat or
decide at all but at least we started to
like circle around what does it look
like
to to do this thing that we talk about
that this whole conference is in
recognizing that human beings are
involved yeah and humans are involved
yeah and that's to lead into the third
clip
i think it's this human element that
that you know that is missing i think
from a lot
of kind of talk about data analysis it's
hard and actually
that gets into like the next topic of
kind of like who's building successful
tools and i think it has a lot to do
with like people who
genuinely have empathy with the user
yeah
so that was empathy i feel like it was a
little but um
yeah like these were
again kind of things we threw out and
didn't think about for a long time but
ended up being central themes to what we
were talking about later
yeah yeah so um that's episode one yeah
episode one covered that
moving on moving on so like throughout
so we kind of have this like timeline of
what
this looked like like evolving over time
and
one of the things and again this was
like four and a half years ago i was
still working at etsy
and etsy had this kind of amazing devops
team
um and so for those of you who don't
know devops stands for developer
operator
and it's this it's this field where um
essentially it was like kind of taking
it to the next level so it was the same
the people who run the website the
people who keep the servers on for the
website the people who
do everything to kind of keep this you
know shopping website
up they should also be the people
developing the tools to keep the website
up
um and so it's like developer operator
and
um and at google they kind of have a
different word for it site reliable
site reliability engineer it's the same
thing and
i was really inspired by that work and
kind of how they
approach problems one of the central
tenants was this idea of a blameless
postmortem
where if you ran into a problem like
let's say your system failed
and the website went down um
there was a there is a human tendency to
like blame the person who wrote the code
that failed or whatever
but etsy focused a lot on instead doing
this thing called a blameless postmortem
where you talk about um like you
you frame the problem as though the
system failed that operator
rather than the operator failing within
a good system
and then that opens up the conversation
to like talk about iterating on the
system
and saying you know okay this person
went to work this day
said they wanted to do a good job they
did not say they wanted to take down the
website
but then the system like allowed them to
take down the website
um and so like based on this kind of
idea of like how do we know what to do
there were sort of these two threads
that started
one was how do we decide like
how to build the artifact like the
dashboard or the email or the report
whatever and then there was this kind of
like how do you build a narrative
um and so i think like the theme of the
early part of the podcast really for the
first year
was focused on that artifact question of
like how do you build
a system that doesn't fail you um
how do you like decide what to do
in order to make an analysis happen that
works for you and
i i was really energized by like
connecting these two things and being
like well
the way we can talk about it as a as a
community
is building systems that help you avoid
errors
and articulating what those errors are
putting cost with those errors
um and then making design decisions for
your system around that
yeah yeah a lot of the struggle that we
had was in terms of kind of identifying
the constraints and identifying the
frame
you know the frame kind of the framing
of this problem yeah
and otherwise it's just it's so open
yeah and like if you don't
define this problem that way um
from like kind of more first principles
you end up in these like nasty language
wars
or you get people who are just saying
like you should use it you should use
knitter and like
and you don't talk about why and it's
like okay
when is it appropriate to use a knitter
if you want to avoid these types of
errors like you don't want to
update your data but have your report be
stale you know like that's a huge one
and so
being able to talk about the system that
way i think
was an important part of this kind of
like threat of thought
um and so again we kind of like
separated out that
and i personally focus on that a lot i
mean we both did but
i think i like that was in my head
because of etsy so much
and then by doing that we kind of like i
kind of purposely like siphoned off the
narrative building and i was like i
don't want to talk about that that seems
really hard
um but then i feel like you ran with
that a little bit well
first first you moved to san francisco
first yeah so i quit etsy
uh and i moved to san francisco and just
as kind of
aside we do this um in the old days we
did this free advertising
and so one thing that happened in
episode 22
was that i talked about a meditation
class i was taking so
hit the clip this is my very san
francisco free advertising we're taking
a meditation class
that i'm really enjoying and so it's
this program called mindfulness-based
stress reduction
and it's it's like a whole thing there's
a wikipedia
it's a whole thing that's the whole
thing yeah yeah
and so again that's just kind of like a
thing that popped up
uh didn't seem related at all but um
ended up folding in later so just kind
of like
planting that seed now so anyway
like i was saying we kind of we kind of
like siphoned off the the
the system design which i think is a big
part of like this conference and other
our conferences
of like how do you do that how do you do
that in a way that is like
user-friendly what types of tools enable
you to do that
but then that left this huge like how do
you convince someone of something
essentially um and so you started to
think about that a lot and you had a
really
interesting episode um where you were
like preparing for a talk
i had to give a lecture i got promoted
to all the
all the full professors that get
promoted at hopkins give a lecture
and um i had to give the talk and i want
and i wanted to kind of i just
want to play some music in the talk and
so i had to kind of figure out some
theoretical framework for like me being
able to put audio clips into the
lecture so i guess that's i mean it's a
reasonable amount that's right and
another professor
had like his entire lecture he's a
biostatistics professor
and his entire lecturer was like talking
about like a wagner
opera right anger anyway no stats anyway
so
you had to like so i started thinking
about you know
i i've had long history music i've
played the violin for
now however old i am 30 some years or
that's how old i am but
that's how long i've been playing um and
you know i've studied music theory
i've done a lot of that kind of work and
um i i just started thinking that there
there kind of were some connections
between kind of what we do as data
analysts and kind of how we think about
music
and this is just a little bit of what we
talked about in that episode
oops the more i thought about it more i
felt like
um there were kind of connections
between what we do in data analysis
what not what we do what we need in data
analysis and
um and kind of music theory right and uh
and so the basic idea
is that you know music is very is
considered to be a very kind of
subjective area like you know in terms
of like what you think is good and what
you think is not good right
um but that said most of us have a sense
of like what sounds good and what
doesn't sound good
right i think i talked a lot about like
there is a theory of harmony there is a
theory of melody
there's a you know in terms of how to
construct certain things and it does and
those rules
don't produce you know the best music
but they do allow us to describe and to
kind of
um summarize what it is that seemed that
people seem to like about music and
it's not an absolute you know theory
it's it's
very kind of based in culture and based
in kind of you know you're
in people's kind of collective ideas but
uh there is a theoretical structure
there
yeah and there's some like science to it
right i mean there's there's literally
like wave properties
there's a little physics involved yeah
and then there's kind of like a
psychology or something you know like
the
like wanting to hear chords resolved for
example like
i'm not totally sure what i don't know i
mean i feel like i'm like i'm like
continue this thought please so i got
very deep in the weeds reading arnold
schwarzenberg's harmonier
and you know the way he summarizes it i
think in the best in the sense that
the theory doesn't say what's right the
theory says what's commonly done
okay um and and so the idea that the you
know the five chord resolves to the one
chord
that's not because it's right it's just
because that's what it seems to be what
everyone does and it seems to be kind of
uh you know not too bad of an idea yeah
um but if you don't resolve the five
chord to the one chord it's not like a
theoretical violation
i'm just laughing because well i
i'm just thinking about that second
lecture uh or the second keynote where
he got like really defensive about pie
charts and i think that's exactly it's
like
it's what people are doing like you
can't argue with that
it is commonly done yeah and so and it
seems to work for i'm with him like for
certain things this is what happens at
our podcast yeah we get sidetracked
and then like two hours later we had so
yeah
okay anyway i'm just trying to
illustrate
that you were right okay yeah so um
so okay during this episode too uh
i sort of bring up where my mind had
been going because so at this point i'd
moved to stitch fix
and i had some like really amazing
people i worked with in the product org
who allowed me to participate more in
product design
um one of the things was doing a design
sprint um which is
kind of a whole thing but essentially
like i could see how design was working
more closely and so hit the clip
it's funny because i was concurrently
thinking about this too in terms of
designers who
i think actually have a very similar
like their placement organization is
very similar to a data like they're
usually kind of a cross-functional team
um like horizontally integrated and then
you also
have um like it's very problem-solving
focused
it's very focused on um like the
it's similar to like the consulting
model um
but i think that they're more willing to
talk about that connection
like design is about the user and
designing for a team like i feel like
when you look at design conferences it's
a lot more focused on that
um but then also their products are on
display so i think that
like sharing what people are doing is is
easier because you literally see
you know design elements on websites
when you go to them
yeah so i was thinking about design at
the same thing here
same time you're thinking about music
theory yeah um i think we thought we
were talking about different things
yeah exactly yeah like two different
ways of approaching this problem
um so kind of in the middle here you
know i brought about like
like getting into meditation more and
then
i essentially like in the middle of all
this so i'm kind of reading about design
and one thing you see when you start to
look into design more is they talk
so much about empathy um empathy for the
users and like
um like that's that's like something
that is
just like an accepted fact about working
in that field
and so at the same time i'm like getting
more into meditation i'm reading more
kind of
like connections between neuroscience
and meditation
and so i read this like really dense
atlantic article
there's a discussion between a
neuroscientist and a buddhist
uh monk and they're talking kind of
about
like um experiences and so um
why don't you like just to be clear this
episode i read the transcript again
i'm still not sure i understand what i
was talking about
data analysis to influence decision
making
has to span both like the world where
third person perspective and kind of
this like scientific truth world is and
then also
that like first person eliciting belief
in another human when you can't really
observe what will make that person
start to believe your results and so
or like trust it so anyway i just i
thought it added clear
to me it added some clarity of like how
the complexity of what we do
yeah so to set that up the idea
was essentially that like a
neuroscientist they can study in this
case they're talking about studying
people who are meditated
and like you can't exactly like
empirically observe like someone's in a
meditative state right like you can
measure their brain waves and stuff but
ultimately you have to rely on the
person telling you that they're in that
state
so you can like correlate the brain
waves with them having that state
and so to me it was like kind of similar
where
in order for an analysis to be
successful someone has to be like
i get it now you know they have to tell
you yeah they have to
tell you that they get it and you can't
observe it like
you can i mean you can obviously see
their face change or whatever but like
it's they're having like a first person
experience and so i was just like
teasing apart like oh yeah you have to
like
use scientific methods and be in this
world of science but then also you have
to like
tap into this kind of like deeply
empathetic thing of seeing
where their mind is and
that's hard i think i get it now
yeah yeah good
do we have other clips from this episode
i don't think so no yeah
um another thing i think we might have a
clip for this one was talking about how
blameless postmortems
like around the same time too i started
to see how blameless postmortems were
well why don't you just play the clip i
think the biggest thing i realized sort
of
almost right after was um
was that in some ways the um
the sort of blameless postmortem stuff
is
is a design process um and
it's a way of almost like making a
system
to force everyone to be empathetic
yeah because the the point of the
blameless postmortem is essentially to
say
you know here listen to
listen to the problem don't blame the
user like try to put yourself in their
shoes like
before they essentially force you like
you can't like use you statements or you
know like there's a lot of stuff a lot
of kind of like rules of engagement
um and so like
it all kind of like started coming
together we're on the path we're on the
path
yeah yeah and the path ends at episode
63.
at least the first milestone yeah which
was the start some of you
if your listeners will remember the
seven part
book club that we had for natural
lacrosse's design thinking
yeah um which some liked some thought
was too long
oh i don't want to hear that but we will
yeah
yeah we'll get we'll talk about feedback
later yeah
yeah so up to the clip here just so you
know
the name of the clip oh and this clip
also really exemplifies the podcast for
people who don't listen
where it takes us a little while to like
get to the point
yes um because you have already figured
that out yeah
um the name of this file is all caps
texting
all right oops that's not
what i was meant designed to do there we
go
and all i know is like i got these like
messages that are like
i guess you took a picture of the kindle
with your phone
and then texted me the picture
that's that is correct and so i'm like
reading
your photo of a kindle
well can you take a screenshot of the
kindle i feel like i don't know i've
never
owned one so i'm not sure oh oh yours
like
tablet all the way definitely um
so then i'm reading these like screen
these photos they're not screenshots
they're
photos of a screen um well no okay
photos of an e-ink screen
yeah i do have a moment of pain when i
see a photo of like a computer screen
and then i think what's what what ensued
was like a series of like all caps
exchanges between you and me
they were like oh my god i can't believe
this is like exactly what we're talking
about
exactly yeah no it was like oh well this
articulates what what we've been trying
to say
in like a few sentences versus
you know you've written a series of long
blog posts i mean i think those are so
valuable
but not concise
yeah so i feel this is the moment where
uh you know we were talking about these
well this i guess
the book's called designing ways of
knowing yeah uh and um
and we were kind of reading it and she's
sending me photos of the book and i'm
reading the book along with her and i'm
like
send me the next page yeah and it was
like so
this was a book essentially about the
theory of um
like academic theory around design and
design work
and it was just like to us it was this
huge aha moment of like
oh it's all starting to really make
sense like and what was making sense is
that
design the way the designers work and
the way that they structure the work the
way they talk about it
you could essentially like swap in the
word data analysis and it was the same
thing
in so many ways yeah in so many ways um
like the way that
designers talk about getting briefs
where it's like
oh you get a design brief and then
the you don't just as a designer you
don't just do what the person
asks you because that will be like a
subpar the person doesn't know what they
want like
they have figured out some way to
articulate it but
your job as a designer is to like zoom
out and be like identify what they
actually need
and then make the best solution about
that but like they're going to
communicate what they need
via what they think the solution is
right and that's the same i mean
i think about that all the time with
like someone asks you for a number you
know they're like can you get me this
number
and then you have to like as a data
analyst you have to zoom out and be like
no okay
what problem are you trying to solve
like why don't you catch me up on what
you're doing and maybe i'm gonna solve
this in a totally different way
some of my collaborators i think would
want me to just give them the number i
know yeah
that's okay then yeah they don't stay
collaborators for long
yeah um that sounded really like way
darker than i meant to talk
yeah yeah i just stopped working with
them it's not like yeah
you don't want that but so
that was that's kind of like the end of
our um audio clips but like essentially
we got to this place where it's like
okay
data analysis is a type of essentially
like
either an independent thing or a type of
design thinking where it's like
the answer to the student's question is
essentially like
adopt this whole other way of like
approaching the world that's totally
different than science and
we haven't like totally as a field we
haven't totally like
like addressed that difference i kind of
wonder what you know what i would have
told that student now you know
more than 10 years later um and uh you
know i think the way that i kind of
think about it is that
when you go outside you don't see a data
analysis walking around
right it doesn't naturally occur like a
tree
or uh you know what else naturally
occurs a rock
right i only know about trees
so if it if it doesn't naturally occur
it has to be built by someone it has to
be designed by someone it has to be
built
and so why shouldn't we use the same
ideas there
um or a data analysis as for you might
for a chair
or a bridge or whatever that's a good
point yeah and like
i mean same with the music too where you
know like obviously noises exist but
like
crafting the noises in a way that's like
pleasing is in many ways
even though it's art it's also design
right yeah and um
yeah no it's a good way of putting it
like essentially you're constructing
something
and then i also think what's interesting
is that
whether you're building like a
production machine learning pipeline
or you're building an analysis like the
tools are different the
types of testing you'll do is different
like kind of like the technical
requirements are different but
ultimately you're doing the same
thing which is like you're creating
something that's going to do something
for someone
right like either it's going to be a
recommender system that creates
recommendations for a website
or it's like this analysis that some
sort of person is going to consume
and make a decision based on that might
just be a pdf document
yeah it could be i mean even like an
literally even an email
with like one number in it it's still
you had to decide like okay this problem
is only this problem can be
sufficiently addressed with an email and
that person doesn't need much context
and therefore if i just send them to
the email that will be enough to like
convince them to do something right
yeah and so that
put us on a really interesting path of
like okay so if we think that data
science is
like a type of design then how do
designers work like if you look at
architects how are they trained
if you look at you know other designers
how do they
work in companies et cetera um and so
one of the things in this design
thinking book by nigel cross
is talking a lot about like you just
have to do it like over and over
um and you're going to get better every
time you do it you're going to go
through different thought processes but
you have to
literally like exercise the part of your
brain that does this constructive
thinking
rather than like the deductive thinking
of science
so um it's like okay so in data science
we kind of
don't do that apprenticeship model so
much i mean
we we i think we wish we didn't have to
yeah
it comes down yeah like we wish we could
just like teach the stuff and be done
with it because it
it's a lot of work to like go through
someone's work and tell them if it's
working or not
but ultimately like if we kind of accept
that this is a type of
design and construction then you need to
be able to like
practice it um so we we did some cool
stuff with that where
um kind of like very different
than uh the types of challenges you do
with like kaggle and stuff where they're
like here's a data set
analyze it instead it was like okay
let's say you had to build your system
end to end like you needed to
answer some questions we did like
commute times right
yeah we talked about well your commute
yeah my commute so it's like in san
francisco it's like i want to know
exactly
like how many minutes and the variance
in those minutes um
for different commute methods so i can
know like the last possible minute
that i can leave my apartment to make it
to a meeting
and um so it's like okay how would you
solve that like what
how would you take get the data to solve
that problem how would you store it
how would you access it how would you
analyze it how would you display it
and then how would you model it what are
the fixed effects what are the random
effects exactly
yeah it's amazing how just a simple kind
of formulation of a problem
can bring in every single aspect of
design of analysis you know presentation
communication
yeah exactly like you're doing the whole
thing
and what i like about it too is that
like the things like how you store the
data
is sort of on the same par as like
what models you choose like all of those
things are equal you have to end up
spending time on all of it
instead of um i feel like as a field and
what
i like about this conference is that
less so here but as a field we focus so
much just on the methods and that
really bothers me in case that hasn't
been clear
um and i was actually i was talking with
someone last night about that where i'm
like you know in some ways
like the way that like normal data
science conference
are um structured it's like everyone
wants to talk about like the like
the best method like the latest thing
and literally
in that system you're motivated to have
bad data
because it like gives you more
opportunity to do fancier models
and so like like any system where it's
like oh okay like
this person could work on worse and
worse data and be like equally happy
because they get to do like all these
fancy things i learned at this
conference
is like that's not solving the problem
like that's
that's like choosing not to solve the
problem so by focusing on the whole
thing it's like no okay like can you
hone in on exactly what data you need
rather than just like
making do with what might be like has
fallen into your lap one way or another
i think one of the hardest things to do
in general but and also in data science
is to
is to kind of uh pull back from trying
to maximize in a single direct a single
dimension
yeah right and i think and i to me the
way i interpreted
even you know jj's talk is like in there
the the way that corporations are
structured is they maximize on a certain
one dimension
yeah um and i think it's hard that can
end up with some good and then some bad
i think in data science it's very
tempting to kind of go for the optimal
approach go for the optimal method go
for the
you know the best prediction but there
are other elements there's other
stakeholders or other trade-offs to be
made
i really like that because in the second
talk
like she just touched it briefly at the
end but it was like
what are ux problems and what are
designer problems
and then the one that was like this is
actually design problem was the loss
function
like it seems like it's just a data
science problem but that's actually like
the core user experience is what loss
function you use and like what
system are you actually building and
what i like about that is that
it's like the same with the corporation
thing it's like what was the loss
function
like before versus that like it like
changed the kpis basically like
i don't know kpi key performance
indicator i don't deal with kpis
what i don't deal with kpi yeah you
don't deal with yet at least
i um yeah like the way i've been talking
about that at stitchfix is like yeah how
do we
rather than just like optimizing for
sales like how can we construct new kpis
that
like might lead to different user
experiences part of it i feel like it'd
be great if we could move to a place
where instead of saying this is the best
thing
we could say you know i really
appreciate this set of trade-offs
yeah yeah yeah so like that i don't know
but doesn't quite
doesn't sound as nice i guess i don't
know
i think it sounds okay anyway i know i
have one person with me here
um one other thing that kind of like the
end of this timeline this has just been
briefly but like essentially by getting
to this place now it opens up like a
whole nother set
of um fields to look into which is
everything around creativity so like
like
all of like the book i'm mentioning that
we're mentioning here is called the
creative curve
and we had like a one episode uh the
club on that
learn our lesson um yeah i was actually
about to suggest that we should do more
like let's retroactively go back and do
like three episodes on that one anyway
um but the the idea with that was that
it was someone this guy allen gannett
who like essentially empirically studied
creative people
um and how they operate
uh and i thought it was awesome i mean i
really liked it it really made me feel
like oh i can apply these principles to
my data science work
um and the principles were let's make
sure
did i i don't think i did ever right
consumption yeah so there was
consumption
so creative people will frequent like
people who well this is why i'm confused
with you so like people who are like
engaged in movie making they watch
movies like 20
of the time like you're not like that
for whatever reason
that's like a different story but like
you know you look at
like just again from like empirically
looking at people who are in these
creative fields
um consuming other people's work is a
big part of it
and like you digest it you think about
it um
and like you iterate on it and i think
that that aspect i mean if you
if you want to write you read a lot of
books if you you know yeah if you want
to write music you listen to a lot of
music and one of the aspects that's
difficult about data analysis it's not
always easy to read a lot of data
analyses yeah because we don't
they're not out there yeah especially in
the corporate world like data science
specifically
like you can read if you have a big team
you can read what other people are doing
but otherwise like
basically only at conferences right or
david robinson's live stream
yeah it's hard to consume a lot of data
analysis i think is what it comes down
to and i think that's a key
step to becoming expert in something
yeah yeah
that's a great point yeah iteration
iteration
yeah so is there imitation too iteration
iteration
yeah so iteration is this idea that you
just like
keep going like you keep trying things
you do it over and over
um and again that kind of is touching
the design literature
too where it's just like you got to keep
you got to keep doing things
and ideas are going to evolve over time
um
and that's part of why we wanted to go
through those clips and put up this
timeline
is that even like the creativity that
we got from this podcast that i totally
wasn't expecting
right like it took us four years like
this timeline is over
like four over four years not the scale
yeah definitely not to scale
and so it just it's like the number of
ways that we attacked this problem and
thought about it
was like a lot and it never
it never felt like it was work
necessarily it was just like iterating
going on and then there's the community
yeah so the community one another one is
like creative communities and so you
look at artists and like
um andy warhol wright had like the
factory i think
and where it was just like a bunch of
artists and a loft you know like
painting giving feedback everything and
so
with that essentially it's like
surrounding yourself with other creative
people
helps you be creative um and so that's
kind of like you know i feel like my um
sitcom like happy ending here it's like
coming to conferences like this
you know they're fun they're energizing
and i do think they kind of embody this
this creative community especially
because so many people are
isolated as data scientists like not
every company has like 100 data
scientists
most companies don't and so being able
to like get together and bounce ideas
off and
see what other people are doing like
like
i guess what i'm trying to say is that
is the work like that's not like this
isn't
productive if that makes sense there was
one agenda item
for the bill for starting the podcast
and i think part of it was to
produce kind of that community for
people who may be
sitting in a department somewhere or in
a
company somewhere by themselves they're
forced to be the lone data analyst
and they don't have anyone to talk to or
they don't have the ability to kind of
hear what other people are working on
and how they're approaching it things
like that so
yeah and that's actually that's like
some of the most meaningful
feedback i hear is when people are like
oh yeah i'm like i'm like alone and it's
like really nice to be able to hear how
other people are working it's just like
yeah that makes me feel really good and
then feedback
feedback yeah so feedback
and this one is is definitely hard we're
like a big part
of in this kind of creative curve book
and just in general
design like you you actively are
soliciting user feedback all the time
right and that's a huge part of it and
you cannot
be attached to what you've produced
essentially like you have to let the
users tell you what to do
and i think that that is like extremely
hard
yeah like getting feedback is hard
and um definitely not something that
people are trained to do right now
yeah um and so and then i feel like i
mean i
i don't know maybe it's just
curmudgeonly because i'm in
like i see it the most but like i feel
like especially in like academic stats
and in data science in general like the
like people do
take it really personally like there's
that quote that i kind of hate
or it's like photographers and
statisticians both fall in love with
their models
like
i feel bad for like but it makes the
point that
[Laughter]
like you see people like really dig
their heels in and there and it's like
it just it gets personal and what i like
is that at least with the user
like i think in the design field there's
a lot more focus on that
and that like accepting feedback um
and then also i mean another thing kind
of like personal hillary's like personal
corner
of like the one thing that did the one
thing i did not expect
from starting this kind of meditation
practice and going down that path
is that it genuinely made me better
at getting like empathy and getting
feedback because essentially like the
whole practice the whole idea
is like dissociating yourself from who
you think you are
so like it allows you to not feel
personally threatened
if someone challenged like
people take stuff personally when it's
like your whole identity is that you're
a statistician and you're smart right
and then if someone says your model is
wrong
it's like oh no i'm not smart anymore my
whole identity is like gone and then
you're like
defensive right and so like
figuring out ways and for me like
meditation and but like just figuring
out ways to like
detach yourself from that makes you able
to take feedback
and then that actually makes you better
at the thing so it's kind of like a
paradox
but it's not like a magical thing it's
something that can be practiced
exactly so yeah like the thing the thing
about the
meditation practice that was a big
paradigm shift for me was that these
things aren't just like fixed properties
it's not just like oh this person's good
at getting feedback or this person has a
thick skin and like that's a set
character trait and mine is not and
that's done
it's like no there are ways to like to
essentially engage in practice that
makes you more robust to that
and and like you know again like looking
at kind of like the neuroscience and
buddhism stuff it's like you know you
can
you're you have like neuroplasticity and
you can like
make new neural pathways that like make
this stuff like it's not just like oh
yeah
like i swear like there there are ways
that you can like essentially change
your brain
um and actually the design the design
the nigel cross stuff goes into that of
like
you know you look at people who are cab
drivers and like their spatial
regions of their brains are like much
more developed you know so
yeah like doing creative work is hard
and it's very different than doing
scientific work and
it's also what we're doing right and
there are ways to get good at it you
know like there's ways to practice it
there's ways to get good like
doing this whole podcast you know it's
like being okay with like
iterating and showing things that will
be wrong in the future
is like it's it's okay and actually
it'll make you better
and that's kind of why i feel like i've
wanted to talk so much about the design
thinking is because
i want people to feel empowered to
engage in that
part of honing their craft
and and not feeling intimidated by it
like i think probably a lot of people in
this room like
don't think they're creative like i
didn't think i was creative and
and i don't think that like i yeah it's
just like identity it's like i'm a
scientist
hillary does science math and science
and
i want people to go through that same
process i went through of like opening
up that side of myself and being like oh
like this stuff all makes me better at
this work
and it's more fun because of it and like
you can do it too like anyone can do it
so anyway that was like sitcom ending
there we go yeah except that we do have
one piece we have one more yeah so that
was like big recurring thing we have one
more
recurring theme that we are not open to
feedback on that's right
so we have one piece of this is the only
data in our whole
yeah you didn't make this an r right
so we do have r in this talk there is
our yeah
the gg plot actually so we have one more
clip
but now we're bringing tea time to the
internet right so exactly
i don't actually have tea today though
but i've also gotten into coffee now so
no i know
so
that doesn't sound right so
uh so yeah lead up to that was that
this podcast in part was we i went to
grad school where roger was
a professor and we had this tea time
thing and that's we had all these
conversations enjoyed them
yeah and it was like oh no i'm into
coffee yes
we can no longer have tea time yeah this
is uh this is where hillary
switches yeah and it really is it really
was post grad school because
it was a long rant but like
most of my life i had bad coffee like
like
i think we all yeah someone was from
another the um
the guy from australia was like talking
about how it's like an experience
to have like bad diner coffee it's like
oh you come to america you have like
burnt dinner coffee it's like it's like
so bad it's good only in america yeah
um so let me just explain on the x-axis
this episode number
on the y-axis is number of mentions of
the word coffee
yeah uh it's good to have transcripts so
yeah thank you stringer package
um so hillary switches to tea to coffee
this is in episode 36 is where i say
people shouldn't talk about drinking
things on podcasts yeah like you go on a
kind of long rant yeah
about listening to other podcasts and
the fact that they're like talking about
the bourbon they drink
that's right and you're like that
doesn't belong on a podcast right like
you were harsh
because i thought you were saying people
shouldn't actively be drinking alcohol
on a podcast and you're like no no like
talking about the bourbon yeah
it's really annoying yeah anyway anyway
so since then
you know we can't say cause and effect
here yeah um but uh
the number of instances has gone up it's
kind of yeah
but uh yeah so literally this will be
the hill we die
yeah and like the last piece of
follow-up is that i
based on feedback i was open to it i got
this mocha pot
to make coffee that's right and i
literally couldn't give it away like we
had a whole episode
right about like if anyone here wanted
it like i am willing to give it away and
no one emailed us that's right no one
wants the book no one wants the mocap
yeah and then last night we got some
more feedback about a new device that's
right
episode 102 yeah we'll talk about yeah
so anyway
yeah if you don't like coffee like don't
talk to us it's like
we're gonna keep on going but yeah so
anyway actually you know i did have a
tie-in for this i was thinking about it
where like to the soul craft as um
shop class as soulcraft where it's kind
of like
you just have to do stuff like it i
started making coffee and then i wanted
to talk about more you know what i mean
like
the more that you do something like you
can kind of fall in love with anything
and you just have to do it a bunch and
you start to care about it
so again it's like the to the creativity
it's like just
just start trying and you'll start to
like it more
and you'll start to feel more empowered
to talk about it and then you'll
bother everyone around you by talking
about it way too much
and then uh and then you'll do a keynote
of our studio and then you'll do a
keynote
anyway so that's our episode thanks for
eliciting yeah
and thanks for our studiocon for having
us here
all right
[Music]